- Ryan Reaves suffered a brutal leg injury last week during a preseason game,
and all eyes are on his injury status.
Here's why everyone wants to see him in the lineup on opening night.
I'm Nasher here with B/R Open Ice, and today we're diving into the rivalry
of the Rangers versus the Capitals.
The two are set to face off on October 13, and this is shaping up to
be an absolute battle. As you may or may not know, these teams, they
have some history. First, let's talk about Tom Wilson.
On May 3, 2021, Tom Wilson caused chaos.
Buchnevich was down on the ice in the crease. Tom Wilson comes from behind
and pounds his head into the ice. As you can probably imagine, Rangers
players did not take too kindly to that, as Artemi Panarin comes into
the mix, pulls Wilson off of Buchnevich and then takes him
on himself. Artemi Panarin, one of the best goal scorers and playmakers in
the league, had absolutely no chance.
Eventually, Tom Wilson rag-dolls him around the ice, throws him down.
He hits his head a couple times without a helmet on.
It is just a terrible situation.
To make matters worse, Tom Wilson then heads to the penalty box, where he
flexes without a jersey on to the Rangers bench.
Eventually resulted in him being kicked out of the game.
This moment right here changed the course of New York Rangers history.
The Rangers ended up firing their GM and president, and now they were on
the hunt for a true enforcer.
That's where Ryan Reaves comes in.
Reaves is one of the last remaining true enforcers in the NHL.
In 686 career NHL games played, he
has racked up 937 penalty minutes
and only 49 goals.
While you won't see a guy like Reaves on the scoreboard very often, he can
easily turn the tides of a game with his energy, aggression and passion.
You have to keep your head up or you're gettin' laid out.
Not only is Reaves one of the toughest enforcers in the league already, he
and Tom Wilson, they go way back.
In 2013, back in Wilson's rookie season, after a big hit, Wilson
dropped the gloves with Reaves, and after a brief little wrestling match,
did tackle him down to the ice. Almost exactly a year later, the two would
meet again, and this one was more than a wrestling match.
Reaves would connect on quite a few punches and drop Tom Wilson.
Over the course of the decade, Ryan Reaves would move from team to team, but
the rivalry still lived on.
How can we ever forget the viral video of Reaves dropping Tom Wilson
twice in just eight seconds?
There's some mutual respect between the two and also some vicious hatred,
and that's what makes this rivalry so special.
These two teams met in the playoffs four out of the last 10 years, most
notably in 2013, where King Lundqvist shut the Capitals out
in Game 6 and 7 to advance.
We can only hope that Reaves makes it into the lineup on opening night, but
regardless, this will be a battle of the ages.
I'm Nasher here with B/R Open Ice. Let's see what happens.